I'm here at the National Institute for
Standards and Technology and I'm about
to see some of the original kilogram
standards as there you are when were
these made
well the originals were made in the
1880s there were 40 of them that were
brethren of the International prototype
kilogram and these 40 were distributed
to the signatories of the Treaty of the
metre and the United States was given to
K 4 and K 20 but was this metre
agreement the Treaty of the metre yeah
what is that as the modern-day
foundation of the metric system so the
u.s. signed that the u.s. signed it as
if they were going to become metric yes
it'll know a secret and I'll tell you
something else that all the units that
we commonly use like feet and gallons
and so on are actually defined in terms
of metric units so it's just a little
translation that we do here but our
country is actually on the metric system
doesn't that seem crazy yes saying that
like you base all of these measurements
on the metric system and then you add a
conversion factor yes and then later
some people have to convert back yes
it's stupid oh good are you allowed to
say that it's true so can we see it sure
sure
what do we have to do set this requires
that we go through some high-security
gear and also that would be somehow
clean and what we do so I'll have to ask
you to put on some loonies here let me
see if I can do this so this is the
first booty Butler that I've ever I'm a
big fan so this is the first layer and
see because
I'm gonna show you two I'm gonna show
you one of the originals and I'm gonna
show you a more modern version this is
Kate 20 oh my goodness so that is like
the original kilogram mass standard of
the US that's right I never thought I
would get this close to it
virtually every mass that has been
accurately weighed in the US over the
past hundred and thirty years can trace
its measurement back to this one
kilogram hunk of 90 percent platinum 10%
iridium iridium makes the alloy much
harder than pure platinum and both
elements were selected for their high
density and resistance to oxidation this
kilogram was created in the same way at
around the same time as an object which
to this day remains the definition of
the kilogram an identical cylinder
stored in a basement vault on the
outskirts of Paris if you look straight
down from the top you can maybe see k20
doesn't have a very nice finish on it
compared to the more modern prototypes
here's K 92 so it's got a much higher
polish on it different manufacturing
techniques absolutely no swirls it is a
really like beautiful looking specimen
yes it is I mean is there a reason why
you want it to look so beautiful
well you want it not to be very rough
because roughness increases surface area
surface area increases the probability
that you will get contaminants on that
will change the mass of the entire thing
how much is it worth
well monetarily the new ones are about
$100,000 a piece if you were to buy one
oh my goodness so but if you think about
K 20 K for with about 130 years of
history they're priceless
you could never replace them the purpose
of this room then is to share the
precise mass of K 20 with anyone who
wants to make a measurement without
sharing K 20 itself what we do in this
suite here is we transfer the definition
of the kilogram from the
platinum-iridium prototypes to
stainless-steel secondaries
and you can tell that they're a lot
bigger and the platinum-iridium
prototypes and that's because of the
relative difference in density the
density of stainless steel is about 8
grams per cubic centimeter whereas the
density of platinum iridium
is about 21.5 grams per cubic centimeter
so there's almost a three times
difference in density which tells you
why this is so much bigger in volume and
that creates a problem ordinarily we
don't worry much about the buoyant force
that is the upward force on every object
in the atmosphere equal to the weight of
air it displaces but since the volumes
of these masses are so different a
stainless steel object that has around
the same mass as k20 can have its weight
reduced due to buoyancy by around 110
milligrams
the precise amount depends on the
temperature pressure and humidity of the
air that's why the mass comparator
itself is inside of a chamber here
that's isolated from the outside world
so that the temperature remains
relatively stable and the humidity the
same pressure is that is by far the
biggest contributor to air density so we
don't want it changing all over the
place with the weather the problem
scientists are having with the kilogram
now is much bigger than weather
fluctuations it's something they
discovered when all the original
kilograms were returned to Paris for a
way in including K 20 how does it get
there it gets there by a person hand
carrying it each prototype gets taken
out of its bell jar and put in its
container which ugly sound after we get
it in there all nicely secured then we
wrap the whole thing in bubble wrap and
put it in a camera bag and sling it over
our shoulders don't let it out of our
sight it sounds a little casual so you
actually like while you're on the plane
do you put it in like the overhead
straps no it stays with us at all times
like it says you know the nuclear
football overcoats were setting off
nuclear weapons and you've never had any
scares while you're carrying the only
scare comes if somebody wants to see it
like a customs official I've never had
open it although I had a kind of a scary
moment at one time when they asked me
what it was made of and I told him it
was platinum iridium and somebody heard
the word iridium and connected that with
radioactivity and kind of you know flew
off the handle a little bit and I had to
calm them down and assure them that it
wasn't radioactive there was no threat
going on here the real threat was the
unreliable weight of the kilogram mass
standard what they do is a series of
comparisons they compare every one of
those with the International prototype
kilogram using that data and plotting it
it looked as if there had been a change
in the International prototype that made
it about 50 micrograms heavier than one
kilogram now over the course of a
hundred years alright but the
interesting thing is if one looks at the
data that was recently taken at the end
of 2013 international prototype kilogram
did not show an increasing mass you're
telling me for several decades it was
gaining mass and all some that stopped
which you know I find that hard to
explain but it seemed like all of the 40
masses seemed to be somewhat diverging
at that weigh-in they went different
ways they went in different directions
yes so that some changed a lot some
changed little some hardly changed at
all
but it's hard to tell I mean they could
we'll all be changing a lot but because
all you can tell is the difference
between them it wouldn't matter all that
matters is the difference between them
and the International prototype because
the International prototype is the only
thing you need the only thing that you
really know because it's defined as one
kilogram
right but I mean outside of that
definition there's a chance it could
have gained you know five grams as long
as they all gained five grams you know I
probably sees ridiculous
obviously it's ridiculous it's politics
but the point is they could have all
been gaining or they could all been
losing right it's a relative measurement
and that's the weakness of the system
and that's why as of 2018 the kilogram
will no longer be defined as the mass of
a metal cylinder
if you want to find out how the kilogram
will be redefined be sure to subscribe
to veritasium
you